um
[Music]
ah
that's good water
hey everybody good to see you all I hope
everyone's doing all right
um I saw some of the
um
some of the chat before we started
uh Evelyn's uh best of luck with the
pitch meeting and
um I think it was Pirates if I am
remembering correctly yes
congratulations on that score on your
test
so that uh hope everyone is
doing well
uh
I'm ready for uh for 2023 to just be
over how how's everyone else
hey
see you keep claiming that Ms Wicked
Wolf and I am not indulging your
paranoid conspiracy theories so
mm-hmm
oh is it Mardi Gras I've literally never
celebrated Mardi Gras in any way I don't
think
Maybe
I went to like a Mardi Gras theme party
in like college or something I don't
think that really counts uh
2023 ending will just lead to 2024. uh
election year
ah
good grief
how can I tell when I'm succumbing to
confirmation bias when it's just as easy
for someone to delete a tweet as it is
for someone else to doctor a false tweet
um
I mean
the general rule of thumb with
confirmation bias is are you taking
something you're reading at face value
or are you looking further into it so
the first thing is to be clear you're
not required to look deeper into
everything that you read there aren't
enough hours in the day however
um if it is something that you are going
to be forming an opinion around or
taking action on you probably should
double check it even if it sounds like
something that makes total sense
and totally jives with your view that is
the best way to watch out for
confirmation bias that I can think of
now in terms of
tweets fake tweets deleted tweets
it gets really tricky and like I have my
own
um
discomfort and like I've done it as well
and so like I understand the reasons to
do it but okay let me back up
there is right now a pretty prevalent
practice
where previously people would just quote
tweet when they want to respond to what
somebody else is saying but it's coming
in it's becoming increasingly common
um especially
um
for uh folks on the left retweeting
figures who are more right-wing to
screen capture their tweet and use it as
an image instead of quote tweeting it
now there is a reason to do that because
when you quote tweet somebody first of
all they're going to see that you did
that so now all of a sudden you're on
their radar and depending on their views
and who you are that might not be a good
thing for you
and there's also the argument to be made
that you make it too easy to get
directly to that person and it's not
quite platforming but it's like adjacent
to it I mean theoretically people are
still going to see the username of the
picture but like it's more work than
just clicking the the link so the I I I
get the reasons why it's become
increasingly common to do that but what
you just laid out is exactly why I have
that discomfort with it if I can't go
back to the original I get very nervous
that I'm not positive now I actually
would say shockingly often if you do go
look for the original it's probably
still there more often than not so if
you move quick you can usually still
confirm it and if you can't
just take it with a grain of salt and
not and understand I that you couldn't
confirm that now that may not be worth
something
um dying on a hill over
if someone's going to be like well this
person said this on Twitter and you're
like I I actually can't confirm that I
don't feel comfortable supporting that
you know it's probably not a hill worth
dying on but just for your own
understanding and for your own
moving forward however you opt to do
John vinyls thank you very much for the
Super Chat ever heard of either Garth
nix's abhorsen series sometimes I wonder
if it was an influence on both the
locked tomb and the owl house I have not
heard of that and
Garth Nix is a name I know I know that
I've seen that name before
I don't know if I'm familiar with the
work though any of it bought hair dye
from Supermarket to make you look more
non-binary any tips
um yes do not use whatever plastic
gloves came with the dyeing kit like go
to go to the pharmacy and get some like
blue latex medical gloves because the
stuff they that if if any kind of glove
came in the kit it is very likely to
tear and you're gonna end up so like
when I did the pink
I didn't realize that the glove actually
tore right here and so you know I'm
doing all this with it and then I had a
pink stain on my hand that I had to
scrub the ever loving heck out of so
that
that's my primary tip
other than that just have fun
uh
I've never been to Mardi Gras New
Orleans I've never I've never been to
Louisiana at all
I I am don't
the South doesn't hold a lot of uh
appeal to me oh hey Meg well we'll see
you when you get back
over the weekend Garth Nix came to
genrecon in the Queensland writers
Center he's a great author I'd love to
see him talk about fantasy and how to
interweave tropes with new life and
sting
do I wear scrunchies generally no I own
a couple I'm not gonna say I never
use them but
what brand color do I use I don't pay
attention to Brands they all wash out in
about the same amount of time I find
when you get a home dye job so I just
look for the color I want I don't really
care what brand it is I'm not a brand
loyalist with most things it's true of
makeup as well
um like most of the lipstick that I use
is Maybelline matte
um
uh matte Inc I think or ColorStay or
something like that that's just because
I know it works well
and I landed on that by sheer
coincidence I've still got other stuff
from other brands
Garth Nix not Garth Enos I'm his hurt
yeah
um yeah Garth Enos would be a whole
a whole other bag of uh
I was gonna say bag of worms that's the
can of worms bag of some no it's not a
bag of monkeys it's a barrel of monkeys
I'd like words whatever yes gartheness
would be a whole other situation I would
imagine
uh
uh first time catching the stream how am
I today I'm all right
I've got more work to try and get done
after we wrap this up because uh I
always feel like I don't get as much
done as I would like but that's that's
my standard operating procedure
I like the technical earrings thank you
these actually got
um picked up off the Amazon wishlist and
were sent to so they were sent to me by
uh by fan which was nice
you're not missing out on much uh with
never having been to Mardi Gras but New
Orleans does have great music festival
called Jazz Fest that has a huge variety
of genres we actually have a jazz
festival in Vermont as well which I've
never like gone out of my way to go to
but I have been in Burlington where it
happens during that time and like have
heard some of the stuff going on and
it's nice I enjoy it
bag of bag of tricks I don't know we're
we're not turning tricks today Gozer
that's that's a weekend activity
ah
interesting day for me tweeted a simple
birthday message for Elliott page
featuring a couple of picks from his
recent Esquire shoot it's coming up to
1500 likes I mean honestly I with all
the transphobic nonsense that goes on on
Twitter it's probably just nice for
people to see somebody not misgender him
for crying out loud
uh
vampires love capitalism because they
can invite themselves into domiciles
with 48 hours notice
foreign
vampires
um vampires are cops because a warrant
counts as an invite
so there's your there's your Twist on
that
uh
let's see
I'm not 255 A.D I'm not entirely sure
what you're referring to there
lighter less complicated question what
is my experience with Pokemon go I was
playing it semi-regularly when I was
running
um so this would have been
two years ago
yeah
um when I when I took up running because
um I would usually wrap up my run and
where it would land me
um well as I got towards the tail end of
it and was getting better at it I I was
ending closer to the house
um but the path that I opted to take it
would usually land me with about uh
anywhere from 10 to 20 minutes left to
walk home after the proper running part
and I'd bust out Pokemon go to pass the
time
um uh that so that was that was my main
experience it was very casual I enjoyed
it it was just it was a decent way to
pass the time
do retroactive warrants work
I dread to find out
uh do you consider root at all to watch
live streams sped up in order to get
caught up
no it wouldn't have occurred to me to do
that
if you love vampires You're Gonna Love
what we do in the shadows I don't
I'm very nervous to try that show I
might one of these days but like I don't
I don't like the comedy style I don't
like that kind of
improvisational I can talk
improvisational comedy stylings where
it's
it's not really scripted like these
people are very talented they're very
good at what they do I just don't love
that style of Comedy I mean it was one
of the issues that I had at times with
um
our with our flag means depth which
thankfully didn't fall into it too hard
at least it didn't feel like it did
Mardi Gras is basically Southern
decadence for everyone including the
heteros
ah braids floats Trinkets and costumes I
I suppose we have to let the straights
have their fun every now and then
Dracula was written as a count for a
reason Iran's about capitalism whilst
plagiarizing a half remembered video
essay well yeah yeah
and I or the other one I like is uh
uh the other one I like is vampire under
d
the translation that I read when I read
that book
was the I don't think the other than the
title of the book I don't think the word
vampire actually appears they just refer
to the vampires as aristocrats
that's it and I love that and I kind of
wish the movie had done that had done it
that way but then again it could have
been an adaptational Choice by whoever
um was doing the translation for the
specific one I read it's hard to know
with things that weren't originally
written in English uh whether it's
um a choice made by the translator that
is either a slight deviation or is super
loyal to the original intent it's hard
to know sometimes
that's upon on Louisiana Louise Ian and
Anna oh okay I got you now
foreign
I feel like messaging my daughter is a
bit off if that was the ultimate Theory
oh goodness
would I rather be a Witcher vampire I'm
quite happy as a witch I'm good thank
you
uh what we do in the van in the what we
do in the shadows is how every vampire
the Masquerade tabletop actually turns
out well might remember remind me of my
old LARPing days from uh from high
school then
John vinyls once again thank you very
much uh a reminder I will try and keep
up with the chat as best I can the only
things that would guarantee that I see
your comment excuse me will be to do it
as a super chat which will also get you
a heart
um from me
um which is your favorite between data
and paranormal Park Centaur world kippo
and the age of Wonder beasts Arcane and
Hilda arcane
I've I was just really first of all
Arcane is I think the prettiest of those
and I was just really impressed with how
well all the characters were handled and
all their stories were handled I'm
really impressed with Arcane which means
I'm both excited and nervous for the new
season
um because when you do something that
good you know are you gonna be able to
do it again
I don't know
that might be a better version of The
Aristocrats joke
dream sounds gets into translation
choices in her little shop of it I still
need to see that one I haven't gotten to
it yet
what's my favorite animated Disney movie
it's funny
um
was actually talking
uh with one of my partners this past
weekend about that and I have a very
hard time I like I can tell you what my
nostalgic favorite is my nostalgic
favorite is The Little Mermaid but like
I do still have some issues with it
I think
I think it's kind of between that
and actually Wreck-It Ralph
um but there are a lot in contention and
it could change at a later date
I love that line from Interview with the
Vampire regarding Dracula fictions my
friend the vulgar fictions of a demented
Irishman
oh Louie Louie always whining
you like this I've had to listen to this
for centuries
that's a good movie I like that movie
uh
do you think not liking anime visual
comedy is part of the reason you didn't
get into avatar The Last Airbender I
mean mean
it probably didn't help but when I think
about why I didn't want to keep going
that isn't really at the Forefront of my
mind
and like I want to be clear I didn't
stop watching Avatar because I thought
it was bad I stopped watching it because
I didn't think it was as good as
everybody said and
I know if I kept watching it I would
feel obligated to make a show about it
and I didn't want to yuck everyone's yum
because everyone else seems to
absolutely love it which is great
I don't like crapping on that especially
when I don't think it's actually bad
it's just
I'm sure if I'd seen it when it aired I
would love it as much as everybody else
I didn't
so I've seen too many things that took
inspiration from it
255 A.D
one of my questions is about the culture
uh whenever that happens it means I
posted my questions late and didn't have
time to think I like to pretend I'm not
obsessed oh well you know we all have
the
the things we tell ourselves to feel
better and then like that and that is a
joke I'm not implying that you are
actually obsessed with this that or the
other I
it you just kind of let you you gave me
an opening to to make a joke and I went
for it
was a good example of deconstructing a
hero protagonist that isn't turning them
into a monster oh
um
that is a
very good question
because the first instance that I could
think of
it doesn't do that but it fakes you out
into thinking that it did that and that
was the Superman story what's so funny
about
um truth justice in the American way
adapted into the animated film Superman
versus the elite
um so that still kind of plays on that
idea
um oh
I'm sure there are some
and the thing is
I think you're probably going to end up
getting into a lot of hair splitting
arguments between what is a
deconstruction and what is a subversion
because I'm sure there were some who
would argue that
um you know heroic characters who are
more liable to
um to run away and rethink the problem
rather than you know go in guns blazing
someone like the doctor could be argued
as a deconstruction of standard hero
tropes I would say it's more of a
subversion because it's not really
trying to say anything about the more
standard tropes it just isn't doing them
so I I think that would be the
um the pedantic Pitfall of of that
question in that conversation
is Arcane going to pay off the Sapphic
plot I would assume so
I think my favorite is Emperor's New
Groove that is a very good one that
that one is indeed
quite good
uh let's see
uh in Frozen Elsa told her sister
Princess Anna that you can't marry
someone you just met notice all
different Disney princesses that want to
marry the prince they just met end up
sad
um I mean I like Frozen especially the
first one is very good
I've seen people say and I don't feel
this way personally but I get why other
people do that it's a little bit too
derogatory towards Disney's own history
and yeah I
the thing is that's not
strictly a Disney problem it's an
inherited problem from a lot of fairy
tales like if you want to take something
like Cinderella or Snow White that's an
inherited problem from The Source
material
and I would argue that most of the
Renaissance ones
while they are working on a fairly
condensed time frame
um you know your Aladdin your beauty and
the beast your little mermaid they are
still getting to know each other a bit
certainly more than something like Snow
White good grief
um so you know
Fantasia sword and stone Wreck-It Ralph
Wally and Bambi are my top five
interesting choices I will keep my mouth
shut about my thoughts on Wally
if you ever watched any of the Moon
You're Gonna Love Ray Hino uh AKA Salem
Marsh who's a lot like you
thanks I guess
speaking about big Gail Thorn I mean I'm
eager to see what she and Finster are up
to I will be very curious to see what
the framing of that
is going to end up being because
Finster is a
creator that I very sincerely don't know
what I think about him
and I don't mean that in uh oh like I
definitely
like there's some people who I don't
know how to think about them because
like
um it's like oh they've got all these
problematic stuff like it's more of a I
don't
I I suspect I don't get it
and because I don't get it I don't want
to put too much too much stock in my own
sort of
kind of low level discomfort
but yeah I don't I don't know I don't
know what to think about Fenster so more
than anything
because I'm very curious as to what the
philosophical framing of that uh video
is going to end up being
uh would you want second seasons for
Moon Knight and the Book of Boba Fett I
know they're unrelated with both kind of
Underdog TV Disney Plus shows Moon
Knight yes book of Boba Fett not really
not really it fell apart so much by the
end I was like I just I don't care
was Ralph breaks the internet a good
sequel in my opinion no no Ralph breaks
the internet was awful it was terrible
it bore all of the sins that come with a
sequel farted out to a standalone
product that was not designed to have a
sequel all the standard stuff of like
giving people whole new issues they
didn't have before so that we can have
them go through an arc basically finding
a reason to reset your main character so
he can be like he wasn't the first one
even though part of his Arc was learning
to be different from how he was before
they did the same thing to Shrek with
the third movie on
like
there's also a lot of tiny specific
things that are much less substantive
but I really did not like Ralph breaks
the internet I actually at this point
kind of hate it
and part of the reason that I hate it is
um because I like the first one so much
well this live stream V up as a VOD
afterwards yeah uh yeah there's a
there's a playlist for live streams or
there should be they should end up there
um but yeah this will be viewable after
we're done
all fairy tales are very problematic
well yes because they were often
structured to try and teach
some kind of lesson or moral and they're
from several hundred years ago when the
moral compass was
quite a bit different so yeah inherently
they're going to be
John vinyls coming in again thank you
very much John I appreciate that would
you rather see a hand-drawn animated
version of The Priory of the orange tree
or a stock motion stop-motion animated
version of the locked tomb I
don't know either of those
so
I don't I don't know
um like I I'm gonna say hand drawing
just because like I would like some more
big budget hand-drawn animation stuff in
general we don't get enough of it
anymore
uh I think for me midnight fits what I
described whilst the doctor wasn't
acting perfectly it's about his
competence and ability rather than his
morality
um
well midnight is about the doctor
failing
massively
I think you and I have a different view
about what midnight is doing and is
about based off that statement
I think Hunchback of Notre of Notre Dame
was one of the best subversions of the
traditional Disney romance between leads
Esmerelda and quasimo and quasi not
ending up together is noticeably
different well I mean
that that's also where you get into a
conversation about the original Source
material because
they changed it a lot inherently but
like Quasimodo in no iteration of that
story and it's gone through multiple
versions including from the same
original author
um but there's no version of that where
Quasimodo ends up with Esmeralda that's
just not a thing that happens
so
I don't know if I count that as a
subversion given that it's in the source
material like it's I suppose it's a
subversion insofar as Disney choosing to
do that story at all was a bit out of
their wheelhouse
um but that specific thing I'm hesitant
to give Disney the credit for that
uh couldn't it be said it's Disney's
problem in that they keep choosing to
adapt fairy tales
I mean yes to a certain extent
um it depends on how far back you want
to push this as
um being a being a problem so how do
I don't want to put this
so a big part of the reason why these
were fairy tales especially in early
Disney I mean the the reason it started
with Snow White and then we got stuff
like Pinocchio and we got stuff like
Sleeping Beauty and the reason for these
things to be based off such well-known
stories was to give them the best
possible box office chance so there is
an argument to be had over how much of
choosing to do those stories was part of
the business reality of the time and how
much of that was
um an actual artistic desire to tell
those specific stories because
it's easy to forget now with Disney
being the monolithic entity that it is
but Disney had a lot of financial
troubles sporadically basically up
through the 90s
um to varying degrees and
a lot of their holy original stuff
didn't do like Fantasia bombed and that
was an expensive bomb
um Alice in Wonderland bombed that
didn't start making money so they
started re-releasing it um to the
Psychedelic crowd so
it
I think it's a different conversation
now talking about what Disney is
choosing to adapt since they can
basically afford to do whatever they
want yes they still want it to be
marketable but the future of the company
no longer depends on
two movies in a row flopping which was
the case for a long time again it's easy
to forget that
uh Lynn Wallace
welcome to being a member snazzy
supporter thank you very much I
appreciate that
uh
I always thought midnight deconstructed
how the doctor is usually able to gain
Trust of strangers on adventures and
talk his way to situations does this
differ from how you see it no but that's
not a deconstruction
of the doctor as a character that's just
putting him
it's a deconstructive it's a
deconstruction of the narratives he's
usually placed in because it's putting
him in a situation where his normal mode
of operation doesn't work and that is
again a subversive thing to do with him
I would not call that deconstruction
largely because it doesn't cause him to
alter his mode of behavior
so
I would say that if you're trying if
you're trying to pull from Doctor Who
you could make a better argument that
waters for Waters of Mars is a
deconstruction of the doctor as a
character and I'm not sure I'd even
agree with that but I would say you'd
have a stronger case for that one than
for midnight
I love Nightcrawler as a subversion of
the heroic narrative
specifically the American dream I'm
assuming you're referring to the Jake
Gyllenhaal film and not the
um swashbuckling teleporting X-Man
do I prefer Frozen two over Ralph breaks
the internet yes yes I do
purple Raider thank you very much for
the Super Chat what musical do you think
is incredibly overrated or underrated
ooh
huh
let me think
um
so
geez this is the kind of thing that like
by virtue of being on a stream I kind of
have to come up with an answer quickly
but I really
I really would kind of need more time to
think about it
um
I mean honestly
a lot of older musicals and I say this
as someone in community theater so this
might not be an issue outside of this
but I feel like a lot of classic
musicals I just don't really care for
because you go back too far and you run
into situations where the songs aren't
telling the story they're just injected
into the plot and that can bug me so you
know you're
your stuff from way back in the day
you know whether it be
um God why am I drawing such a blank
I mean a lot of the Cole Porter stuff uh
for instance kind of falls under that
um
underrated
on well I mean for stage I just I really
wish more people knew Next To Normal
because I think that one is amazing
um
I haven't really been dealing with I
mean I find I find West Side Story to be
highly overrated any version of it so if
we want to go with film
um as far as underrated on film
I it's cheating because it's a TV show
but gallivant way more people should
should know and love galavant than do
I'm back in this musical theater talk I
did what I did wonder if you were gonna
manage to catch this sort of thing Meg
um so anyway what do we got we got we
have more
uh we have more Super chats we've got
255 A.D coming back in thank you very
much obsessed is the wrong word I think
I feel toward the culture how a lot of
other leftist nerds feel towards Star
Trek culture is just not mainstream that
makes sense that makes sense to me
Josh Tyler thank you for the Super Chat
I've got to go now stay safe everyone
have a lovely night you too I hope you
have a wonderful rest of your evening
our philosophy is thank you very much
for the Super Chat should our position
on consuming Harry Potter change if the
IP ownership changes
um
maybe so
here's the thing
about
um
about that
it's that we need to remember that JK
Rowling is using two things
in her push against trans people one is
money the other is prestige notoriety
and while
the change in hands of the Harry Potter
franchise would
at least cut off future source of money
from that specifically
um although it would uh presumably
involve someone buying out the IP right
so Lord knows how much he'd make on that
but even setting that aside it still
leaves the issue of
the notoriety that it grants her
and she would still be able to cash that
in to be seen as relevant and important
even if she didn't own the IP anymore
because she can still use that notoriety
of like this huge massive thing that
Millions upon millions of people love I
created that
even if she's not still in control of
the IP I made that I made that listen to
me I have thoughts I have thoughts on
trans people she'll still be able to
wield that regardless of who actually
owns the IP the only thing that would
change is who the money goes to which is
part of the problem don't get me wrong
but as people who think it's a reason to
not do anything are so fond of pointing
out she already has a ton of money so
the money actually isn't even really the
big problem the bigger problem is her
continued relevance the fact that she is
considered a big enough name to
be interviewed to be talked about to be
discoursed about I mean the comparison
that's very easy to make is if you
compare her
to Graham Lennon
and the fact that
he basically has done nothing except be
transphobic for about we're going on six
years now I think
nobody talks to him he only comes up
within internal discussions because he
injects himself into these things but he
he's a footnote
nobody is having discourse about Graham
Linehan
but they are about JK Rowling because
Harry Potter remains so popular and even
if you cut off her funding that
popularity will remain which makes her a
continued relevant figure which means
she can still wield that attention
against trans people as she has been
so I suppose what I'm ultimately coming
down to is
no
no I it it would not change my position
I might get less emphatic about it
simply because I know that there would
be many out there who would find the
position less tenable but for me myself
and my own personal views no I don't
think that would change where I stand on
this
I mean another person you can look at is
Orson Scott Card
when his massive homophobia became
increasingly obvious
I'm not going to say it was the cause of
the love of things like Ender's Game for
dropping off but
the decline in interest in his Works
meant that
people also
weren't listening to him
they just weren't like he probably had
things to say for days about gay people
but he was rarely talked about unless
there was something like an adaptation
of one of his books
he was only relevant relative to that
and new people weren't coming to it
Harry Potter keeps getting refreshed my
generation and people slightly younger
than me keep reading it to their kids
and they're passing it on and they're
passing the interest which is sustaining
the property which is making the whole
thing have a much longer shelf life and
understand that for a franchise to be
able to do that is incredibly impressive
that is an oppressive thing and I don't
want to belittle the idea that Harry
Potter has Notions and ideas and and
thoughts and themes worth embracing it
does I used to embrace it
but it's continued relevance means that
she can and will continue to swing
attention every time she says literally
anything
and that
people will interview her and reference
her and discourse her because Harry
Potter continues to matter
and if interest in Harry Potter had
dropped off after the last movie
and had just Warner Brothers realized oh
what we're paying for this license isn't
worth it and they backed off
I don't think we'd be in the position
with her specifically that we are right
now because
she wouldn't be as relevant
I went out for a bit on that one
ah
so where are we
uh John vinyls once again thank you John
you're being very generous this evening
and I appreciate it I would personally
love to see an adaptation of fairy tales
from non-euro-christian cultures that
keep the cultural aspects of their
Source material I.E a version of the
original Jewish incarnation of the
Corpse Bride story that would be
interesting
I'd be up for that the the big caveat I
would have on that is
um do that by putting the means to fund
these things in the hands of those
cultures not just hire a consultant to
help the same standard people who always
make these movies make yet another movie
I mean better to hire a consultant than
not hire a consultant but you know
let people tell their own stories maybe
thought
princess psych thank you for the Super
Chat what are your thoughts on Resident
Evil it is a series I never got into
um
the best shot I would have had was maybe
Resident Evil 4 but uh and like I do
have it I have it on gabecube but it was
around the time I started falling off
video games
um in general uh when that came out oh
hey Jessie good to see you
um so and and I didn't like the stuff
prior to that because it had the the
tanky controls which I hate
um and at this point I know they've all
been remade and whatnot but like as I as
I've pointed out many times I get motion
sick from fully rendered 3D games so I
like I'm probably never gonna
excuse me never gonna get into it
Tara stahler thank you very much for the
Super Chat just popping in to say hi do
you still plan on seeing the prince uh
and if you do are you're going to review
it on YouTube I do still plan to see it
I had hoped
hoped to find the time to see it uh
yesterday I didn't I am going to try and
see it this week I like I'm behind I'm
behind on stuff and I've got some
catching up to do I'm trying to get to
it will I review it
I will say something about it I am
certain of that whether it will be a
full proper review I don't know it is
largely going to depend on what it is
that I think about it
so I don't have an answer for that
Supreme
Omega thank you very much for the Super
Chat uh on Long running franchises do
you worry when fans who grew up on the
older stuff uh start to take charge just
look at Doctor Who track Jeff Johns at
DC I mean like it's always a hazard
um
in terms of
you know fans
see the other things you mentioned the
thing I would actually say fell into it
the hardest was Star Wars
most of the Star Wars stuff that has
happened has felt very
to varying degrees
fan ficky especially rise of Skywalker
um but it's kind of the same issues I
have with the Mandalorian it feels very
fanfic to me and I think that comes from
you know people who
grew up on it wanting to wanting to see
the things that they've imagined in
their head that weren't in the movies
and
like that's admirable but yeah it's it's
hard it's difficult to inject
um
you know fresh ideas and fresh blood
into it
um when it's being run by fans but at
the same time you get people who aren't
fans and they might not understand what
it was that made the original good so
like there's there's
hurdles and traps either way
what's worse The Black Cauldron Chicken
Little or Home on the Range I've never
seen Home on the Range and I've only
seen part of Chicken Little
and that was worse than Black Cauldron
if you were forced to make an adaptation
TV or movie of a property you love what
would you trust yourself with
[Music]
oh that oh
that
is an
interesting question
um
I
would hmm
uh hold on I I want to come up with a
good answer for this like I want to like
run and look at my bookshelf
and like just look at stuff and really
think on it but okay uh let me see
um
foreign
I think the easy answer
would be the dristy Worden books
um by R.A Salvatore or Salvatore I don't
know how his last name is pronounced
uh uh the only reason I'm hesitant on
that is because I don't know if I'm able
to do something better than just well
polished but somewhat generic fantasy
action take on it I feel like there's a
better answer
but I'm drawing a bit of oh
I know what I would want to adapt and I
would have to go into witness protection
after doing it
um lamb The Gospel According to Biff by
Christopher Moore
that that is the one
what do you think about the rumor of
Moffitt coming back to Doctor Who to
write episodes I have no opinion on
rumors I will have an opinion when it is
confirmed yes the Discord thank you
carowind I will get to that so
um I am gonna be popping over to the uh
Council Geeks Discord which is a patreon
exclusive I need to answer questions
that are in there apparently there's a
lot of them I will get through them as
quickly as I can and come right back and
obviously you get to hear my answers to
those questions so stay tuned and feel
free to drop in super chats or whatever
in the meantime if you have questions
there oh boy we do have a lot okay
starting with an oddball question but do
you think it's odd that super stretching
the power such characters as Plastic Man
elongated man Kamala Khan as Ms Marvel
or Mr Fantastic doesn't crop up as often
as say characters who are based around
super strength or speed or energy blasts
um I
think it's that odd simply because it's
it's a superpower that requires more
creativity both of the writer and the
artist and while some writers and
artists will Revel in that for others it
becomes a big pain to try and keep
thinking of new and interesting ways to
make use of that or depict that or Draw
that or what have you so no actually it
makes a lot of sense to me because you
have to remember as ambitious as any
artist or writer might be they're
working on a budget monthly issue so
they need something they can crank out a
regular pace so I'm not surprised that
they kind of avoid that one why do you
think Barbarian Heroes speak to people
as much as they do personally I think
it's the idea of a person more at home
with the Primal nature of things being
able to overcome the hypocrisy and
shallowness of so-called civilized life
and looking forward and looking awesome
while doing it in essence putting a
mirror up to so-called modern society
showing that it's not nearly as advanced
um as it might like to think it is but
that's just me well I mean if you're
talking about characters like Conan the
Barbarian sharing it's just
sometimes it's just fun to see somebody
wreck shop
I mean that that's that's kind of how
how he how characters like that tend to
work and I think I think there is an
appeal to the Simplicity of it because
you know we live in complicated times
complicated worlds but
boy wouldn't it wouldn't isn't there a
little bit of an appeal to a time when
if you could swing the biggest Club you
just win
I think there's an appeal to the
Simplicity in that with Wizards being a
hot button topic do you think the name
is ripe for the Wizards Arch and enemy
to get their day in the spotlight I
speak of course of Barbarians
a fantasy series akin to the Wizard
series that won't be named but focusing
on the awesomeness uh that is a
barbarian in the lion cloth um I'm
assuming when you bring up Wizards in
this context you're talking about uh
Wizards of the Coast I mean like any any
group or organization that can get its
foot in the door
um on the back of Wizards of the Coast
having uh pissed off as many players as
they did go for it get in get in there
you know make make your stamp get what
you can
answer me these questions three what was
it like doing drag in New York City uh
stressful
it is very very clicky or it was when I
was there and I never felt particularly
welcomed
by the uh by the New York drag scene
there is a there is a high density of
people who are just as big a diva off
stage as on which exhausts me quickly uh
what's the furthest south south
why can't I talk tonight
this is probably why what's the furthest
south you've traveled in the USA Florida
which is kind of a cheat because like
gone down there for relatives or for
Disney World and I feel like going to
Florida is like skipping a whole bunch
of the South because it's Florida is its
own
weirdness it doesn't necessarily feel
like the South or it didn't at the times
I was going there I don't know what it's
like now uh when you went to college did
you know what your major was going to be
or did you figure it out on the way I
thought I did change Majors twice
neither time doing the major that I
should have just done believe it or not
I was initially an accounting major and
then I was an English major I should
have just been a theater major I might
have actually finished if I'd done that
if you had time and patience what one
skill would you acquire uh you do not
have and why I just like to be able to
play a musical instrument
um ideally something that isn't as
common
I don't know like uh like the harmonica
I think that'd be real cool or like to
be really good with uh
with a um
Irish pipe or a pamphlet or a knock
Arena or something
that'd be real cool I don't have the
patience though if you could visit one
other single time period in history
where and when would it be I'd no that's
the kind of question I can never like
come up with a
particularly satisfying answer in my
mind
um for
I don't know as much as I like time
travel Stories the idea of actually time
traveling myself
at least in terms of oh wouldn't it be
fun to go back to experience I'm like I
I guess
as like a tourist sort of I don't know I
just I can never come up with a decent
answer to that battle ax or Morningstar
depends on whether it is a flail style
morning star or not I don't mess with a
flail if it is a standard Morning Star I
will take that if it is a flail Morning
Star I will go for the battle ax and if
you're asking me why it's because the
battle ax you have to be sure you swing
it with the edge and I worry about
accidentally hitting with a flat or
something you get a morning star there's
Spikes all over that thing you swing it
and hit it's gonna work
um why do you think there's so many
wildly different opinions about which
are the best episodes of the chip null
era usually if an era of something has
been poorly received there's at least
one thing that everyone can agree on
being good like Wonder Woman for
instance
um
well I think part of it has to do with
the fact that there are some people who
genuinely like the chipmilera OR at the
very least like it more than a lot of
other folks do and so they have a
tendency to gravitate towards
um different favorite episodes than the
people who really didn't like it and are
just looking for anything they think is
good that having been said I feel like
most of the fandom has coalesced around
Haunting of villa Dia Daddy
uh which is ironic for me to say because
on rewatch boy did I have some
massive problems with that episode wow
but yeah it's
it does it it doesn't have its version
of a midnight or a heaven sent where
it's like this this is how good it can
get it's so yeah it is a little odd that
way
um why is it that way I I don't know it
I think it's just weird because I think
it this is the first time where it felt
like the people who weren't happy
outnumbered those who were mostly happy
because like there were plenty of people
who were loud during moffett's Reign but
it felt like most of the fandom was at
least being like yeah no I'm still
having fun
do you agree or disagree with Millie
Bobby Brown when she says show Runners
are too precious about letting
characters die and Max should have been
killed off at the end of stranger things
4.
um
I agree with her sentiment I don't think
I agree about Max in specific I do agree
with the general sentiment though
I'll give her that
ah
do you think spider Sam Raimi Spider-Man
movies have been tainted
uh now given the mixed response to
Doctor Strange 2 because they use the
traumily stability Trope so prominently
I don't think so
I think most fan assessment of those is
still pretty positive at least for the
first two and I don't
at least I haven't seen people like
change their opinions on those because
of that stuff I mean the use of
problematic tropes that's that's all
over the dang place it's either gonna
bother you enough to take the experience
or it's not I don't think that that has
changed too many people's minds about
something they already had an opinion on
uh like speaking of someone who talks
about tropes like that my own General
thing is that I
when I'm sick of a Trope I am more
likely to
resent seeing it again in something I
haven't seen before rather than have my
opinion turned around on something that
I already liked that also uses that
Trope if that makes sense
uh art oh boy
okay let's get into the heavy topics are
trans people more uh endangered in the
US or the UK both you and Jesse Evan why
you think it's the UK and I don't
understand why like there aren't parts
of the UK that are outright Banning
adult transitioning so you actually kind
of answered the question for me there
collectively as a country as a whole I
do think the UK is worse
however the parts of the US that are bad
for Trans people are currently worse
than the UK basically here's what it
breaks down to
the degree to which trans people are
endangered having their access to
medical things taken away are being
discriminated against in the UK it is
happening basically on the national
level pretty much all this stuff when it
happens it's happening to everybody in
that country
in the U.S at present we are not dealing
with Federal
legislation restricting the rights of
trans people it is state by state so
what that means is there are parts of
the country that are way more secure and
way safer and some parts that are very
much not safe and those that are unsafe
are worse than the UK
Texas Florida Tennessee Oklahoma
a bunch of others Arizona probably soon
those are all worse than the UK but they
are also not the entirety of the U.S so
it's sort of a case of whether your
question is taken collectively as a
whole or are the worst things in each
country the worst things currently
happening are happening in the U.S but
the stuff that's going on in the UK
you can't escape them unless you leave
the country whereas in the U.S you can
go to a different part of the country
and be safer which also doesn't make it
okay because people shouldn't have to
flee their goddamn homes but there we go
do you think you'd find it a lot harder
to boycott Harry Potter stuff if
everything uh coming out of that
franchise wasn't awful and perfunctory
at this point like something I keep
thinking about excuse me is what I do if
she pulled an RR Martin and the seven of
the book was just coming up coming out
now and I had decided I had to decide
between finding out how the story ended
and supporting her
um
I think
I think in many ways that leg is
Hogwarts Legacy in particular was an odd
case because there have been Harry
Potter games before but they were tie-in
games for the movies and generally
weren't very good so the idea of having
a high quality product
that tied into this franchise people
love got them excited in a way that
honestly
because child didn't none of the
Fantastic Beasts movies didn't I don't
even think that the theme park did
it got it got more people more excited
than they've been in a long time and I
think in the absence of something like
that specifically we might be seeing
more of a tapering off but that did a
lot to re-energize interest in the
franchise uh even from people who kind
of walked away for me because they're
like oh how cool would it be to explore
Hogwarts
and that kind of thing can Revitalize
interest
um
not quite to the level that like
waiting on the last book of the
franchise might but as close to that as
you're going to get for something that's
theoretically finished
uh remember I said I was wondering if
you'd find the state of the art
frustrating uh this was a this is a
story I that is on my docket to read for
uh commissioned reviews suppose someone
opted to leave the culture to live in a
more primitive Society because they
think having to work to survive makes
life meaningful do you think that's a
reasonable Viewpoint because I don't and
that's why I find the story frustrating
don't think it's an unreasonable
Viewpoint it's just not a Viewpoint I
share
I don't share it at all but I don't
think there's anything unreasonable
about somebody making that choice for
themself
I can understand choices that I wouldn't
make if it is presented well in
characters that I can understand if not
necessarily relate to so I think that's
what it'll come down to for me when I
get around to it all right I'm back in
the chat I'm out of the Discord I'm back
in the chat
uh uh we have Okay so we've got a couple
of new super chats Meg
being cheeky
a theater major you already excel at
drama
I try to not get into drama I really try
I don't succeed but you know whatever
Supremo Mega back again thoughts on
Watchmen being exploited in multiple
prequels and spin-offs to the point Dr
Manhattan thought Superman is now part
of the main DCU very stupid shouldn't
have happened was inevitable
like it was I I'm actually shocked
that it took as long for that to happen
as it did
I'm legitimately shocked that they
waited as long as they did before doing
literally all that it was always going
to happen and it was always going to be
a bad idea
ah
Witch Doctor older knew would you like
to be a companion to
um
probably two
I think I think I'd have the most
Pleasant time because like 12 is my
favorite but I also think I would
irritate him
have you heard about in the news about
the changes being made to roll dolls
books to make the wording more modern EG
not use the word fat and Charlie in the
Chocolate Factory huh
hadn't heard that
um
if they are in fact changing the word
fat in specific I'm gonna kind of [__]
my head at that
because
most body positivity Advocates aren't
saying you can't use the word fat
in fact fat Liberation is a
pretty big part of it
it is generally a word that is what what
most people advocating
for fat acceptance are doing or trying
to take the stigma off the word
because there's nothing wrong
with being fat
and using a different term doesn't
really
change all the hatred that's often
poured into it so if that's if that is
one of the specific things that they're
going after that strikes me as an odd
thing knowing how Roald Dahl was I would
say I would hope that they would be
looking at some of the specifics in
terms of the backstory of the Oompa
Loompas because
whoo boy
oh boy but you know that's me
I'm finally playing Dungeons and Dragons
for the first time
excuse me our party did our first level
up can I just say paladins are
ridiculously op
um I actually have never been in a party
with a paladin
I've never been with a gaming grouper or
anyone wanted to play the goody two
shoes
so I I actually don't have a lot of
experience with paladins playing with or
as
um but if they seem ridiculously op uh
just wait for your DM to
make some adjustments
based on your very limited knowledge of
Pokemon what's your favorite Pokemon I
Evie
there there we go
saying fat is fine using fat as a
negative descriptor not so much yeah
like that's not a word where I'm like
the words the problem no like the
the meaning you put behind the word is
the problem
Augustus Loop is an inherently fat
phobic character unfortunately yeah
that's true quetzala and that's kind of
the thing like
it doesn't if you're trying to fix the
fat phobia you have to kind of remove
the character
but
you know if you're not going to do that
you can't remove the fat phobia from the
nature of that character
by just not calling him fat that's
that's not how that works it's baked
into everything about that character
I am morbidly obese I'm okay with people
using the word fat but for some reason
pleasantly plump gets me to smile more
that that always is just a nice turn of
phrase isn't it
ah
uh I'm gonna wrap it up soon
council is a fat safe place damn right
damn right absolutely a fat safe space
right here
I saw the Oompa Loompas are described as
short people instead of short men that's
the only change I've heard to their
description I re oh boy
it really sounds like they uh they are
not being very wise With The Changes
they're making because
like the Oompa Loompas
he went into a foreign nation and
tricked them onto a boat to come back
and work for his Factory and he doesn't
even pay them with money
ah the problem with the Oompa Loompas
was not the implication that they were
all dudes
BMI oh BMI is so messed up anyway like
that's it's this stupidest damn thing it
does not distinguish amongst other
things aside from being a stupid metric
in the first place it doesn't even
distinguish between fat and muscle
it just takes weight
it's very dumb it is very very dumb
uh did you hear about Virginia Hayes
major health problems lately oh she's oh
she has new ones I know about some of
the stuff she's had in the past
do I like the word thick I enjoy the use
of it I don't make use of it myself
because there's some I am not taking a
side in this debate but there is some
arguments made about whether
uh white people using that is uh
appropriating a um
a Black Culture term I don't know where
I stand on that but I know that it's
enough of a thing that I just I I smile
hearing it I don't use it
uh one of my top five favorite pieces of
media and why oh we do not have time for
that when I'm supposed to be wrapping
things up
hold on to that one for next time Alyssa
um
originally they were literally described
as pygmies but that got changed in the
second editions I believe and like let
me also be clear there's nothing wrong
with updating over time like
one of Agatha Christie's best books is
currently titled and then there were
none
prior to that it was called Ten Little
Indians prior to that it was called
something that it was called ten little
something I will not repeat on stream
so like it's okay to change these things
I have the original with the
illustration show the Oompa Loompas is
black
[Music]
oh dear
oh
in the witches a description of them as
bald under their wigs as followed by by
a new line there are plenty of other
reasons why women might wear wigs and
there's certainly nothing wrong with
that
all right these feel like Band-Aids over
more inherent structural problems
yeah that um
um yeah uh set 666 uh abominy uh as
carowind pointed out I have reviews for
Owl House in the break room of Geeks I
do need to wrap it up we did get one
more last minute Super Chat thank you
John vinyls should we also disown Philip
Sydney for defending the Elizabethan
conquest of Ireland in the 1500s
uh
hang on let me make sure I've got my
facts straight on something here
okay so you are talking about the
historical figure I mean
is anybody still massively repping for
Philip Sydney
is is is that a is that a thing are
there big massive
Philip Sydney stands
I
I don't think in general you need to
disown historical figures you need to
understand their full context
and you need to not turn to a blind eye
to things that they did just because
they were an important part of a history
that matters to you
that's kind of the same issue I have
with the deification of the founding
fathers in the U.S
it's not that I think that they were
horrible people and we shouldn't have
some pride in the things that they did
or think that they were
um great in many ways but like
to forget the fact that Muslim owned
slaves
and had other things that weren't great
about them besides that's
that's not dishonoring them
to be aware of that that's part of who
they were
great things can be done by flawed
people pretending that the people who
did the the bits of history that you
like were perfect doesn't help anybody
a purple Raider oh people sneaking in
last minute with these
um what would you say is your favorite
pre-moffet era Moffat story I.E empty
child doctor dances girl in the
fireplace Etc go on the fireplace for me
uh for me it is
oh it's close it's either empty child
the doctor dances or silence on the
library force of the dead and I don't
know
which who is moffatt uh he was he was a
showrunner on Doctor Who for a while Meg
huh uh but yes okay I gotta I gotta talk
about what is coming up uh tomorrow if I
can get the damn edit done there should
be a review for a no not a review a
ranking for the episodes of series 12 of
Doctor Who and then
um
I will also be streaming tomorrow on
Twitch playing Rogue Legacy two I'll be
streaming uh again on Friday probably
the same game we'll see how I'm feeling
Saturday's video uh is actually going to
be annoyingly on Ezra Miller not because
anything new happened but just because I
kind of had to talk through my feelings
about
whether or not they are going to be kept
around
after the flash comes out and I think
that should do there will be a review
this week in the break room for
um the new Ant-Man
uh movie
and that should
I don't know what day that's gonna be
out I'd hope to get that out today
that didn't happen so we'll uh we'll see
we'll see when that gets out but it will
be this week
uh
not saying I I approved Council of Geeks
it's what I have my that my parents
bought me oh no I understand that
homebody I understand that no you did
nothing wrong don't worry about it I was
I was going wow to the existence of the
thing not the fact that you owned it
like no don't don't worry about it don't
worry about it all right
am I ranking them from best first to
worst again no because actually the
choices are obvious at both ends this
time so you know whatever anyways
um that'll be it for this one thank you
for joining me everybody I hope you have
a great rest of the week
um and please remember that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
mccavity